we are here with the one and only molly
sims
what is what are you teaching us today
molly teach us okay first of all i'm
going to talk about the importance of
packing cubes you can get them anywhere
walmart amazon wherever you want to go
these will change your life because
everything is packed so when you're like
going through your suitcase to try to
find something you can just okay i'm
going to put this here i'm going to put
this here if you have kids
families whatever it's so easy you can
roll you can fold
underwear swimsuits t-shirts ziploc bags
i know plastic don't don't judge me they
work you can literally put outfits
just like a packing cube
into
ziplock bags so you can reuse them over
and over and over again over and over
and over
eco way too much
a ziploc but i have my i have my
ziplocks that i've had for like five
years i keep using them and i pack in
outfits so as much as i'll do a plastic
ziploc i'll do
like a hanging with exact outfit like i
knew what i was gonna come and wear
today like i thought it out less stress
also toiletries
don't leave them out don't put them in a
packing you put them in something that
it's this is
going to spill bummed out and you're
going to hate it um i'm going to
challenge you for my next little tip
okay here's what we're gonna do when you
pack you have to learn to roll
so
i'm gonna challenge you
because i know you travel and i know you
know how to roll a few things you know
how to roll a few things all right are
you ready uh-huh uh okay we're gonna put
30 seconds on the clock okay ready and
see whoever can roll more articles of
clothing to put them into their suitcase
wins ready
go
when it makes
it different i know it's crazy
[Applause]
by the way
[Applause]
um
well um i i think we both won this
challenge i'm really i started talking
yeah listen this is uh let's just hang
out more molly sims you can listen to
molly's podcast lipstick on the room
wherever you get your podcast
[Music]